you got to admit though if we're a
society that gets really upset about
jokes that's a sign we get it we got it
pretty goddamn good you know some guy in
Ukraine's getting his face shut off we
got people out here like
zingers always blows my mind when
somebody gets really upset about comedy
I told a joke one time this guy got
pissed he goes you got to apologize for
that joke I was like sorry he goes you
didn't mean that apology I'm like I know
I didn't mean the joke either you
queef what are we doing
here but you know maybe it's me I'm too
literal literal guy you know definitely
hurt me in some social interactions yeah
I remember just last week I was at a
party girl comes up and me she goes are
you gay I was like no I'm not gay she
goes whoa another wrong being gay I'm
like yeah I know just saying I'm not
she's like well you're getting pretty
defensive I'm like well I'm not gay
she's like well there's nothing wrong
with it I'm like I know but I'm
not she wouldn't let it go eventually I
got annoyed I go what are you pregnant
she was like screw you I'm not pregnant
I was like whoa another wrong being
pregnant